new lengths one will know
I've never liked formula one I always
thought it was populated by kind of
people who wore snow washed jeans and
terrible Blue Zones with perms and it
was a bit nerdy and sort of 20 okay so
yeah so being faced with thousands and
thousands of hours of formula one when I
first started working on Sena wasn't
necessarily great prospects that day I
suddenly realized that I was no longer
driving it conscious and I was in a
different dimension for me the circuit
for me was a tunnel which I was just
going going going and I realized I was
well beyond my conscious understand
how does it work working with another
editor during the center how was the
process well he and I never works at the
same time okay
his work had finished by the time I
started on it so it wasn't really a kind
of collaborative collaborative process
he worked quite a long time and cut
quite a lot of scenes right they've got
to a big rough cut but I had sort of
reached an impasse
where I don't know I think that putting
those scenes together in the first
instance was so time-consuming to trawl
through all that material for the first
time and get those big story blocks in
place that they kind of I think think
it's got very tired and they got very
inside the material as he would do yeah
and so I came in as basically as a fresh
pair of eyes and as somebody who with a
bit of a reputation doing it being able
to draw a story out because at that
point I think the story had got lost a
little bit
for me I thought before I went to watch
the Fiona is gonna be kind of informal
things you know for more things about
Sena how he lived his life you know like
a little history book and I end up with
this really really strong drama yeah I
mean I was keen for it to be the story
of the man and not just a series of
episodes of that Greatest Hits greatest
moments of his life there had been
compilation documentaries made of his
greatest moments lots of them yeah
particularly after he died you know
every TV channel with who did Formula
One put together a kind of clip reel so
I didn't want it to be that an order
Asif at all we wanted it to be the story
of the man and Anthea the viewer to be
able to watch him grow and watch him
change in emerge but also to play it
like a just go and D thing you've done
quite a lot of documentaries is that is
that where you're most interested in
all well I do do dramas in between adhan
mostly documentary and I mean I just
fell into those by accident really and I
mean in fact I failed the documentary
component at film school
yeah which so always stroking is
terribly ironic an alligator but but
actually in television in in the 90s
when I started editing TV documentaries
it was the most creative part of
television you you know it was little
films that you were sent off to make
there were no rules it wasn't that you
were making something for a specific
audience you could experiment it was
much freer I love that and
and when I did dramas again I found them
sometimes a bit constricting yes
and so I tended to end up working with
documentary directors who also did
dramas for whom the scripts was just the
starting point I see who would shoot in
quite a loose way they may handhold
so I don't really think once he worked
like that it's not that much difference
between the two fields you're just using
grammar and filmmaking techniques to
tell a story
so yeah the boundaries aren't that
strong really I mean I digress for a
moment I've always thought documentaries
are that anyway are just in you know
that I think the term documentary was
invented by I think it was Robert flatty
who said that the documentary is cinema
which tells real stories using the
grammar and devices of narrative cinema
yeah yes hope you know it was that's
what you should be doing you want to
excites and amuse and enthrall people in
exactly the same do the way you do when
you're making a drama yeah it's right I
mean I think that the photo accident on
the end we didn't come true and I
wouldn't feel like as I felt if I don't
see how how it's and are behaving in his
personal life can you engage that he he
has he has a sense to his own own
country for example and he's and he's
going home and and firstly firstly being
the Brazilian race in Rio I felt that
actually that was the moment when I felt
like really really got it this is all
something big happened I got very kind
of very emotional watching film
absolutely hooked you know I thought
it's really powerful
and lots of different things
particularly the funeral scene at the
end you know when it cuts between his
family members going to the coffin and
yeah moments of their lives it does it
makes people weep quite often really
really cry yeah you know because then
the emotion in that room was very very
strong anyway I mean that big
grief-stricken sense of mourning is
fully there but to then flash back to
him again as a younger person with these
people his girlfriend and various
girlfriends and his parents yeah no I
mean it's a very strong moving
you talk about the process your own your
own approach when you sit down with the
brushes and how you how you basically
clean the film I generally like to try
to get a cut together fairly quickly I
never have a paper edit or anything like
that
it's literally day one of the Edit is a
blank page of the script yeah and you
start where we want to start telling
this story and it's the best way to be
excited about it how we're gonna tell
this story to start and you just do a
scene where do we want to go next
where do we want to go next and feel
excited by that process and do it very
quickly and try and get to a cut within
weeks okay first cut you never do but
that's what you've that's the post it
you start off doing and that way you
feel the story emerging with you and you
start to find the story and you get more
confident it means you always go back
and redo your beginnings 80 times
because you haven't you get into the
grammar of the film the film starts to
dictate its own terms after a while but
it also it just keeps you in that
objective point of view you do get
obsessed of course you get down to my
new tie quite quickly but if you're
cutting quickly mashing it together
really making it as good as you possibly
can in a short term you know with music
everything in there whatever effects of
you know that are available on an avid I
get in there there and then so it's a
very much a blueprint it's quite a I
always do quite a polished first rough
Kafka yeah it's not just an assembly I
never do sink pools or any of that stuff
I just dive in make the film
is there a particular subject that's
interested you that you'd like to maybe
edit something about one day not really
no I mean I think you're amazed by how
interesting things he wouldn't have
thought would be interesting end up
being and with Formula One being a great
example I mean it always comes down to a
story for me is it a story it usually
has to be something you know that you
could tell in a pub you know if you if
you can if you can tell it to somebody
over a beer it's probably will work in
the end so I mean I think you have a
responsibility as a filmmaker to your
subjects first and foremost you don't
want to do anything that's going to
upset them or make them feel like
they're being misrepresented but at the
same time you your job is to find the
bigger picture and quite often you see
things that they can't see because they
were inside the events that were
occurring and psychologically sometimes
you can observe particularly
observational documentaries you can see
things happening you can see people
behaving in certain ways that they're
probably not aware of themselves I did a
film called hardcore about a woman and
English woman going into the adult film
industry in America and she wasn't aware
of why she was doing this but it became
acutely obvious to the director that
there was trauma in her life that she
was kind of acting out and we
constructed that film and it became a
psychological profile the action that
was taking place was all a mirror of
what was going on inside her and the
turmoil that she was suffering and
watching that with her for the first
time was incredibly difficult she was
weeping and she hadn't seen this she
wasn't completely aware of why she was
doing it you have to be very very
careful about not letting your wish to
tell a great yarn override your
responsibilities in the subjects
because we have responsibilities to the
larger truth because possibilities and
the people who contributed to your film
as well
you